c'est du déjà-vu pour chantal leba cher
sa mère de 92 ans a déménagé deux fois
de résidence
en l'espace de deux ans et là elle n'a
eu que deux semaines pour plier bagages
très difficile et là encore aujourd'hui
cette semaine doit la d2 laperne on a
dit bon on va laisser la période
d'adaptation mais si celui-ci ait lieu
des pleurs qui se font elles peur le
beaucoup de pères mais on ne pose choix
un climat de tristesse règne entre les
murs de la villa champêtre en matinée un
des résidents a tenté de s'enlever la
vie
mais et s'en sort avec des blessures
mineures un intervenant se rappelle lui
avoir parlé la veille
soyez sûr que vous allez vous voir puis
un homme dakar mjl quel nouveau parti
trop journée lors dans l'émotion on
rentre avec on rentre avec le sourire
pour montrer aux résidents qu'on est là
pour les soutenir mais malgré que là car
nous arrache puis c'est pas une bonne
journée
c'est lourd des journées semblables des
centaines de familles en ont vécu au
cours de la dernière année selon la
fadoq une centaine de résidences ont
fermé leurs portes depuis un an un peu
partout au québec on évoque comme raison
les coûts devenu trop élevé pour les
plus petites résidences la
réglementation la lourdeur de
l'administration les exigences de
formation du personnel et les services à
offrir à une clientèle vieillissante
on est très inquiet pour la prochaine
année où les deux prochaines années
quand on regarde la situation de plus
près les beaucoup de résidences qui sont
en difficulté devant de tels
bouleversements les familles se sentent
impuissantes s'est précipitée s'est vite
et puis faut tu te retournes sur un ton
en dessous d'un code 1d et puis c'est
pas évident et on se remet au fait que
josh beckett est habitué mais après j'ai
jamais passé par çi je partirai pas de
là bas
rires qui cache une inquiétude bien
palpable ici laurence bellot mr radio
canada trois rivières